hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game i was suggested to me by
colonel dino
uh he passed his trainer's exam uh by uh
feeding not so long ago and now he's
finding all these
very nice games and this is one such
game uh where
well i'm not going to spoil too much but
it's uh
it's a one that you don't see very often
and you'll see why it was played in 1995
in the austrian under 14 championship
between uh matthias borchowski and the
ma vice and
as i don't have a photo of my vice of
course we are uh wearing a hoodie to
honor the hoodie guy
i do hope you guys are wearing a hoodie
as well as you know uh
we can never honor the hoodie guy enough
and uh
i thought twice about showing this game
or not because it's you know it's summer
in croatia and we're wearing a hoodie
it can get very hot in here but okay
let's not
uh make this too long then so here uh
white opens uh
with uh b4 we have the polish opening
and the black replies with knight to f6
if you remember
uh fischer often suggested just uh
counter this with e5 even though
you will get this attacked it doesn't
matter fischer just suggested this this
and this and that
black will have a very very very nice
game
so if you want that you can listen to
fischer or if not you can do uh
whatever you want we have knight to f6
and the bishop to b2 we have d6
and c4 now uh we have knight b to d7
and e3 so preparing d4 and white will
get
control a lot of squares here black did
not uh
did not go into into what white actually
wanted to play
so uh we have g uh sorry g6 by black
preparing to fiance to the dark square
bishop castle king side
and knight to f3 with bishop to g7 and
bishop to e2 so both players just nicely
developing pieces we have castles and
castles
and this is not a photo of uh matthias
from 1995 uh as you know it was under 14
championships so this is his uh
photo where he's a little bit older as
you can see but
uh only means that he continued playing
chess um
uh even afterwards so whereas uh same
cannot be said for ma vice or maybe
uh maybe he he has but we were just
unable to find any
uh any information about it uh but okay
c5
black strikes in the center wants to
control uh the d4 square and now while
you could capture
and let's say play d4 with e6 black is
perfectly comfortable
so instead after c5 we have b5 grabbing
more space
on the queen side and this is also a new
move in the position
one move that was played in this
position was a3 but b5
is a new move or rather as this game was
played in 1995 it is as of move eight
that this position has never
uh happened again so b6
uh preparing to fianchetto the light
square bishop and the d3 now we have
bishop to b7 and now
knight b to d2 preparing rookie one
knight knight of one knight g3
and so on so e6 and queen to c2
developing the queens
connecting rooks and d5 now
white allowed it so black gets rid of
his weak d6 pawn
with rook f2d1 in the now queen to c7
black
also develops the queen connects the
rooks they are now bros for life as we
sometimes say we have h3 taking away the
g4 square
from black's pieces and rook after d8
that's not a d8 rook f2 d8
uh and rook 8 to c1 and now of course
black counters white's rook as well so
rook 8 to c8 and all of the pieces are
now nicely developed
now it's time to get them to better
squares so knight to f1
shifting the knight over to g3 we have
a6 challenging the b5 pawn but the white
just pushes a4
and now black has to decide whether he
wants to maybe capture and bring the
rook over to a8 to claim the
the a file maybe maybe do a nice rook
lift maybe double up who knows what can
happen
but instead black just closes up the
at the queen side and white continues
with knight to g3 and now even
e5 by black so what can white do here
now white
goes rook to b1 for for some reason
i i don't know what the reason is but
for some reason
we have d4 by black and now white closes
the position with
e4 so now we've closed off the queen
side we've closed off the center
and now the only uh place where there is
a left
you know there's room left to play is
the king side so let's see what happens
rook f8 black now prepares to move the
knight and strike with f5
so bishop to c1 white also has to set up
his pieces to
to act accordingly with knight to e8 now
preparing f5 and the knight
the h2 uh with f5 and now white
three df-3 square for his pawn so f3 and
the black continues pushing with
f4 and now knight to h1 but now also
h5 and now the only place where
black can now even strike is the g4
square so at some point
g5 g4 will be played and white needs to
be ready for this so bishop d2 but now
g5 we have rook to f1 and
now knight d to f6 now
g4 needs to be very well prepared and
this is uh black's next plan
so knight to f2 with rook to d8 with
queen to d1
now the queen and bishop will help out
with the defense of the g4 square also
the two knights are nicely placed
and bishop to c8 now black also now
positions the bishop to help out with
the g4 thrust we rook to b2
and then now bishop to e6 preparing to
bring the queen
on the same diagonal as the bishop rook
to c2
white is helpless so white needs to just
wait and see what happens and king to h7
also uh black wants to bring the rook to
g8 and
push the bishop back so the rook will
also help out with the defense of the
no with the attack on the g4 square with
knights to h1
and now knight the g8 shifting the
knight over to h6 so then both of the
knights can help out with
the attack on the g4 square king f2
white knows what's coming so he starts
bringing the king to safety and now
queen to d7
also helping out uh towards the g4
square
king e1 and now we have knight e to f6
now this knight is coming here this
knight is coming here knight back to f2
now both of the knights are also
guarding the g4 square and now
knight to h6 and here rook to b2 white
just uh
has to wait and see what happens but
black says
it's not time for g4 just yet so rook to
g8 preparing to move the bishop so the
rook helps out as well
so bishop to c1 and now bishop to f8 and
here you see
uh all the pieces working together uh
towards that
g4 square even the dark square bishop
would help but he's a dark square bishop
he can't help
you know it's a light square so here
king to b2 white just continues uh
running away with the king and now
finally we have it now that everything's
prepared
uh this attacks this attack so this
attack said this this
uh g4 g4 is coming so here
g4 is played and i don't know if you've
realized it or not but uh while we were
preparing for this uh
g4 on slot not a single piece or pawn
was captured it's already it's already
moved 37 and
we didn't have a single capture in this
game but now the first capture
also turns into a capture fest so let's
see what happens here
g4 is played and now of course we have
captures we have captures
then comes captures we have captures
white ghost captures we have captures
captures we have captures captures
captures
uh and after captures captures of course
there is captures
so uh uh we had a we had a word full of
pieces and now we have nothing so
we've now just it down into a nice uh
rook and bishop end game but if that was
a bit too overwhelming because i know it
was too overwhelming for me
let's check that out again in slow
motion so after g4
we have h capture sun g4 now of course
you have to recapture this
captures now you're threatening this to
win material so white of course captures
we have again knight captures here you
capture there's nothing better you have
captures captures and again
there's nothing better bishop captures
bishop captures
everything is forced this is uh this is
a true the immortal capture fest
uh queen captures we have captures
captures and
now that the g2 pawn is under attack
white needs to defend it and here
uh maybe uh maybe an idea is to play
something like rook h1 move the king so
this
rook would uh i defended the but the
white played uh rook to g1 and
it seems a bit passive uh but that's
because it is uh and okay this doesn't
work because if you do this the king
just moves and you don't really care you
have this sufficiently defended
so instead after look the g1 we have
bishop to h6
and now comes king to e1 not allowing
any nasty discoveries here
king to e1 and now comes rook d to g8
with a double attack here uh now f3
might be an idea
so king to f1 but now uh feel free to
pause the video
and try to find the winning move for
white sorry for black
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it uh congratulations on
spotting the only winning move here uh
so that means you are an excellent
endgame player and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
rook g3 and the point is the pawn cannot
be defended
uh because if you try something like
this then this rook no longer defends
the pawn so you can just capture that
and other than that really not much not
much you can do
if you go rook here then f3 of course is
incredibly strong
so here uh what do you do uh well rook
to d2 just
f3 so white tried rook to rook to b3
uh and now f3 also works for example you
can play f3 let's say captures captures
and then
uh or or even better after captures you
can do an in-between captures with
check king f2 and then recapture uh it's
just uh
just a completely lost position for
black it's uh not
not even playable you're just going to
bring the king in and that's it
so here after rook to b3 uh the
mr hoodie guy or ma vice just played
rook to g6
sort of a sort of means of improving the
position i guess first
it doesn't really change anything uh we
have bishop to d2
and only now uh we have f3 and okay now
bishop captures an h6 we have
f captures on g2 a nice uh uh tuition
soog we have king f2
and now king captures on h6 now rook a3
white still doesn't have all that many
moves you can't move the rook otherwise
pawn g1 wins you can't move this rook
as this pawn falls so it's very very
very very ugly to play this position
with white rook a3 was played but now
king h5
king e2 was played but now king h4 and
it was in this position that matthias
burzowski
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
point is that whatever you play and you
really don't have all that much to play
this
rook still cannot move this rook can
move but where you could go like the a1
but then king h3
you could go somewhere with the rook
there aren't all that many moves rook e3
check and now once you move
uh you're gonna get rook g to g3 and
that's it uh
this is a complete two swung and uh you
don't have any moves so let's say king
c2
king h2 and now whatever you do it's
just over this rook cannot move
uh because this pawn falls if you like
move this rook then
i mean nothing happens uh you you can
always capture here and if this captures
captures captures and king captures here
and then you just promote a pawn so
white is uh literally without a move
here
so after king to h4 uh black uh white of
course knew this and uh
it was in this position that he resigned
the game so really really uh impressive
game
uh a monster capture fest on g4 it was
truly truly an honor to present this for
you
and uh thank for thank you uh chronology
for
uh suggesting this game it was uh it was
a very very enjoyable
and now before i forget do check out the
first link you will see in the
description below it is another
masterpiece by agar matarino where you
can see
me fighting against paul morphy and
mr barnes uh it's really really just an
epic battle
so yeah uh that's uh the game i do hope
you enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
uh
guillermo magnol uh
chris shell and adam young for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing
the coverage of the morphe saga checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day